detalles una nueva masacre azota a
Estados Unidos 5 personas han perdido la
vida y más de 25 han resultado heridos
aquí en Colorado Springs en una
discoteca gay ahora mismo muchas
personas que siguen acudiendo al lugar
de los hechos para mostrar sus
condolencias para también algunos de
ellos Mostrar mensajes de contundencia Y
repudio a lo que es este tipo de
incidentes que no recuerdo lo que
sucedió en la discoteca pols de Orlando
precisamente aquí en Colorado el
gobernador yard polis que ha hablado de
la importancia de dar recursos a la
policía para que esto no pueda suceder
de nuevo es el primer gobernador
abiertamente homosexual de Estados
Unidos tenemos Pues un nuevo episodio de
matanza de problema con las armas y
también del odio hacia la comunidad
homosexual